ADAM DAWES: Hi, everybody.
I'm Adam Dawes.
I'm a product manager at Google
on the Identity team.
TIM BRAY: And I'm Tim Bray.
I'm a developer advocate on the
Identity team at Google.
And we're in the business of
trying to get people to--
ADAM DAWES: Get out of the
password business.
TIM BRAY: And so recently I
wrote a blog piece about why I
thought that was a good idea
and people should get into
Federated login.
And apparently I didn't quite
convince 100% of the people
who read it.
ADAM DAWES: No?
TIM BRAY: Yeah, there were
some comments which--
well, let me try and represent
the feeling I got from some of
those comments.
So I have my tin foil
hat here, and it was
kind of like this.
You want to capture all my
information, so you give it to
life insurance salesman and
credit check agencies, and
then you're going to shovel all
the data over the wall to
the NSA so I can never buy a
pressure cooker again in my
life without having a full body
cavity search every time
I take a book out
of the library.
Are you crazy?
ADAM DAWES: Tim, settle down.
Settle down.
Take the tin foil
hat off, please.
We can talk about
this rationally.
Now people do get a little bit
exercised about a lot of these
issues, which is a
very good thing.
I mean, these are issues
that matter.
And there are concerns that
people should examine as they
look at Federated identity.
But I think the important thing
to think about is, that
when you go and you're logging
in throughout the internet,
you're going to be relaying
some amount of information
about yourself.
You can do it sometimes in a
pseudonymous way, but you're
out there in the world.
You're interacting with other
sites, other businesses, and
they have a legitimate right
to want to know something
about you, to make their
services better or fulfill
their own requirements.
So I think we need
to make sure that
we're held to standards.
That we do what users think we
should be doing as far as
their privacy goes.
And the alternatives are, of
the current system, are
generally a lot worse.
TIM BRAY: So on balance you
think that whereas the
concerns are real, we probably
come out ahead.
ADAM DAWES: Yeah, I think the
security of the system today
is actually pretty abysmal.
You could argue, some people
think that the privacy
features are better, but I think
when you dig into the
details they're not actually.
There's not a whole lot
of savings there.
TIM BRAY: Fair enough.
Now if you actually dive deep on
all the different technical
concerns people raised, which
we'll do some in a minute, and
there's a lot of them--
I thought there was sort of
a subtext, which was,
we don't trust you.
And in general, people don't
trust people who
are identity providers.
And let's be honest, people seem
to generally not trust
Google and Facebook.
So how can we address that?
ADAM DAWES: Well, we're
big companies.
We're in the business of having
a lot of information.
So skepticism, I think,
is warranted.
But again the question is, you
have to trust somebody.
As you go out and you do
business out on the internet
or out in the world, you have to
relay certain parts of your
identity and your self in
certain circumstances.
So you're going to have to trust
people with some public
facing pieces of information.
The question is, how much
control do you have?
How much visibility do you
have in what's going on?
And I think we work hard to
try to be very clear and
transparent with our privacy
policy about exactly what
we're doing with your
information.
And at the end of the day, we're
really trying to build
great user experiences--
not just on Google products,
but really to make the
internet more and more
useful to people.
Google's business improves as
people use the internet more.
So that's one of the goals of
our team is really to try to
make it easier to go out
and do what you want
to do on the internet.
TIM BRAY: I think one good way
to improve trust is just to
improve competition, have more
of an open ecosystem.
And I note that as of yesterday,
Wordpress is an
identity provider.
So I think that's nothing
but good to have
more people in it.
So look, we could spend the rest
of our time here talking
about what we think you ought
to care about, but I noticed
that on the Google Moderator
for this thing, a bunch of
pretty decent questions
popped up.
So rather than do that, why
don't we talk about the things
that you actually have said
you're interested in?
So the first one was, oh, OK, if
it's important that users,
this is Bryant in Seattle.
By the way, hey Bryant,
good to meet you.
I noticed you put a lot
of questions on
our Moderator here.
If it's important that users
be able to choose their
identity provider, why is it
that large service providers
like Google don't accept
Federated login?
Why can't I login to Google with
open ID connections from
my own domain.
So Adam, you want
to take that?
ADAM DAWES: Actually
Google does do
Federated identity today.
All of our Google Apps customers
have the ability to
configure via SAML their
own identity provider.
So typically that's some sort
of Active Directory kind of
endpoint that will do the
authentication for the users,
and Google becomes a relying
party to that.
So we do support Federated
identity.
In some cases, why don't we
allow Federated identity to
any random identity provider?
Well, just as I said, you
have to trust somebody.
That doesn't necessarily mean
you have to trust everybody.
And there are repercussions with
allowing anybody to get
into Google's infrastructure
and log in to an account.
So we see a tremendous amount
of attempts to abuse Google
infrastructure.
So the basic example would be,
if we allowed anybody to use
whatever identity provider they
wanted, and that identity
provider was not very secure,
and was easily hacked, and
people could compromise those
Google accounts by logging in
via that identity provider, then
a whole bunch of Google
resources become available.
We're not protecting, we're not
the gatekeeper for those
Google resources once we trust
an identity provider, a random
identity provider.
TIM BRAY: In fact, the original
idea, back in the
original Open ID proposal, was
that everybody should be able
to nominate their own
identity provider.
And I just have never been
convinced that's going to fly.
My feeling is we are probably
going to be living in a world
of whitelisted identity
providers, one way or another.
I mean, the notion of us maybe
relying on Facebook doesn't
seem insane to me at all.
The notion of us relying on
whatever identity provider
they point to in the world,
ugh, that one
gives me some heartburn.
ADAM DAWES: Those accounts
would have to be severely
restricted in terms of
what they could do.
TIM BRAY: OK, should an identity
provider be able to
give relying parties not just
access to information but
policy on retention
and controls?
Why can't I give access to my
email address for a month?
So, that idea doesn't
sound insane to me.
But as far as I know,
we don't do that.
ADAM DAWES: So we actually,
our terms of service for
Google+, actually
allow people--
when you disconnect from a
relying party, the Google+
Developers terms of service
mandate that the identity
provider actually delete all
the data, except for a very
small portion of kind of core
profile information.
Having a lot of information
come from the identity
provider is one thing, but when
you're actually using an
identity provider, you're still
creating an account on
that relying party.
And just because you stop using
that identity provider
doesn't mean that account
goes away.
So the relying party still needs
a few core pieces of
information, like email address,
to be able to service
you if you want to stop using
that identity provider but not
stop using that relying party.
TIM BRAY: Having said that,
in the basic low level--
bottom-level OAuth 2.0
protocols, there unfortunately
is not time retention.
When you give somebody
somebody's email address, you
just give it to them.
And I suspect, in most cases,
they would retain it forever.
So that's actually not something
that I've seen come
up in the standards
groups and so on.
But it doesn't sound like a
crazy idea to me, so maybe we
should be thinking about it.
ADAM DAWES: OK, next one.
Can I bribe you to give
Persona a spin, Tim?
TIM BRAY: Well, OK.
Just on the subject of bribing
me, go for it.
I'm down with that.
But on Persona-- so I actually
have been looking at Persona
and started diving into it
deeply, actually, last night.
And so far, I've got to say
Persona looks about OK to me.
I haven't so far run across
anything about it that's
irritating.
A couple of low-level
API characteristic
glitches, but you know.
So after I've gone and done
that, you don't even have to
bribe me for this.
I will write about
it at length.
ADAM DAWES: Yeah, I
think Persona is
an interesting project.
Definitely wish them well.
I think the browser ID stuff
is pretty interesting.
That has some really nice
privacy features.
The Persona service itself, I
think probably the coolest
part about that is just the
privacy policy that goes,
that's attached to it.
They have a nice story there.
AUDIENCE: So speaking of which,
Tim, there was one
question on YouTube.
First of all, I think HR and
legal immediately contacted me
to say no, you cannot
accept bribes.
And it's in violation of
Google's terms of service of
you as a current employee.
But the follow on, we
got a question from
KickYouInTheThroat
over on YouTube.
And he says, I'm not
wearing a foil hat.
I'm just concerned
about the policy.
So what we want to do is kind
of address some of those
people who aren't possibly
wearing the foil hats but are
concerned about the
current direction.
TIM BRAY: Right.
And, you know, comedy term
was irresistible.
How many times do you get a
chance to wear a tin foil hat?
And I probably got in aggregate
between Google+, and
my blog comments, and Twitter,
oh, 200 or 300 feedbacks of
one flavor another on
the thing I wrote.
Of which, there were a few that
were pretty well, you
know, ooh, evil corporations.
But I thought actually the vast
majority of them were
pretty sensible.
And that's why we're
doing this.
And that's why we're doing
an ongoing series on
my blog and so on.
So pardon the tin foil
hat theater.
I wasn't actually talking
about you.
ADAM DAWES: I thought the series
that Tim opened up on
his blog was really
eye opening.
We do this every day for a
living, and so we can get
sometimes a little bit
in the bubble.
And opening up this dialogue has
been really great for us
to really understand
how passionately
people feel about this.
And we're going to work to try
to a, be more transparent
about it and see what
we can do to
lessen people's concerns.
TIM BRAY: And one of the
interesting things is that we
know, we have data that shows,
there's a certain number of
people when they show up to a
website and it asks them to
create an account and a password
and sign in, they
just hit Command-W, make
the window go way.
I'm not doing that.
I've had enough passwords,
no more.
So there were a few people who
wrote back in the dialogue
online saying, well, when they
see a sign in with Facebook,
sign in with Google sign,
they hit Command-W,
make the tab go away.
They don't want to deal with
that, which kind of puts all
the people out there building
websites in a tough position.
Which of those factions is
bigger, and how are they going
to survive in a world with both
those factions in it?
ADAM DAWES: I think one thing
about Federated identity--
the Facebook Connect
technology's been so
successful.
It's so broadly used throughout
the internet that
that's sort of synonymous
with Federated login.
And Facebook Connect, for the
most part, does mean a fairly
significant exchange of
information about the user to
the relying party.
And it's very clear to us
that that is distasteful
for a lot of people.
They don't want to share
all their friends, give
permissions to be able to write
to their stream, all of
these sorts of things which are
fairly serious privileges.
But Federated identity
doesn't have to be
that broad in scope.
It can be extremely narrow.
Persona has taken a very narrow
approach with only
communicating your
email address.
So there is a middle ground,
and we're also working to
support very basic levels of
Federation where very small
amounts of information are
transmitted, and have that be
a completely seamless experience
to the user.
TIM BRAY: And at the end of
the day, let's not dis
Facebook too much, either.
Because a lot of people
like what they do.
In many cases, social login
is totally appropriate.
ADAM DAWES: Yeah, for many apps,
the apps are not very
useful if you don't have their
friend list, if you don't have
the capacity to write
to their stream.
I mean they're just not very
good apps, without having that
basic level of functionality.
But it's not for all sites
and all users.
TIM BRAY: OK, time's
moving on.
Let's move on here.
OK, should Google and other IDPs
make a clear declaration
of what they will do with the
information that you've signed
into an app?
Apps must declare which
of your information
they wish to access.
Should the IDP be required
to state what they'll do?
ADAM DAWES: So yes, at a basic
level we should do this.
We have a privacy policy and we
do explain in our privacy
policy generally what we do
with your information.
And probably the most important
feature is we don't
share it with others without
your permission to do so.
All the Federation flows
actually have in it a consent
screen which says, we're about
to give information about you
to somebody else.
Are you good with that?
So that is a core essential
principle of
everything that we do.
Now what we do internally, a lot
of the questions sort of
had concerns about what we
do internally with the
information that we learn
about via Federation.
And I think this has been a good
takeaway for me, that we
need to try to be a little bit
more transparent with what
we're doing.
I think the reality is, today
we're not really actually
doing anything with
this information.
It's sitting in a log file
someplace and then gets erase
after a certain period
of time.
But there is a lot of work going
within Google to try to
understand more about
our users.
We have a very strong conviction
that the more we
understand our users,
the better we can
provide services to them.
So things like Google Now are
predicated on having a fairly
rich understanding of the
interests, the activities,
what users are up to.
TIM BRAY: Let's just take
the focus away from
Google for a second.
I think the only sane answer
to that question is, yes.
Whenever you provide information
to somebody, in
this case the information about
who you're signing into.
It has to be clear what's
happening with that.
So at the moment we've got the
privacy policy which doesn't
say anything specific about
this particular class of
information.
Maybe it should, maybe it's
good enough as it sits.
We'll have to work our
way through that.
ADAM DAWES: OK, next one.
Shouldn't IDP always allow
users to refuse access to
requested information?
This could lead to a broken
experience if the relying
party isn't expecting missing
information, but after a while
RPs will just learn
to deal with that.
So I think, to sum this up I
think this is, on that consent
screen, is their ability to say,
no I don't want to share
my email address or this
piece or that piece?
TIM BRAY: Actually, it's
all over the map.
If you go and look at the
different consent screens from
different parties, for different
classes of access,
some of them, in particular
Google+ is a
good advantaged example.
It gives you very fine
grained control.
Yeah, they can see, these people
or not those people, or
they can't see any people.
And they can do this,
but not that.
And yeah, as the questioner
says, the RP has to be
prepared to deal with that.
Others, it's basically just--
including some of ours, to be
honest, it's just a yes or no.
Yeah, they want your email
and your basic
profile, is that OK?
Yes or no?
And we don't provide
fine-grained control.
ADAM DAWES: So this is actually
something that's a
hot topic with us these days.
I think the questioner makes a
good point that the relying
party, they ask for a certain
body of information.
And if they don't get it they
don't know necessarily what to
do with that user.
On the other side some
functionality might be
predicated on having access to
certain information, and so it
makes for a lot more
complicated in app.
What we're thinking about right
now is to have more of
an incremental way
to deal with it.
So an app can ask for very
little at the very beginning,
and then as you march through
the app and interact with
different pieces of
functionality in the app, to
ask for those additional
privileges just in time.
So the context is clear, and the
user kind of sees what the
quid pro quo is for giving
access to that information.
TIM BRAY: It's horribly
complicated.
The user experience, people give
us no end of grief when
we want to be pestering user's
all the time for this
permission, that permission.
Also, there's the unfortunate
fact that if you look at the
statistics, there's a
substantial proportion of
people that just click OK
whenever you put something in
front of them.
And don't even think about it.
And every time you make the
dialogue more complex and
subtle, the proportion that
just click OK goes up.
Because they don't want to take
time to be reading that.
So we want to not pester
people excessively,
particularly if that's going to
decrease the security, but
on the other hand you
would like to offer
more fine-grain privilege.
No, I don't know what the answer
is, but it's something
we got to keep working on.
ADAM DAWES: Yeah, I always find
this the great conundrum
of this job, is on that consent
page I'm not sure if
it's better for the consent
rate to go up or
for it to go down.
TIM BRAY: OK, so this
one's easy.
And we're running out of
time, so I want to take
a couple more here.
Is there any way to
retroactively revoke just some
of permissions I've given
away by Federating?
Like if I log in with Google+
in an app, can I keep
authenticating and let them see
my email but revoke post
to my Circles?
And the answer is--
ADAM DAWES: Yes.
For that one in particular,
not all constellations of
privileges can be individually
managed that way, but with
respect to Google+, Circles,
and posting,
that you can control.
TIM BRAY: What can an ordinary
web user do to decrease their
exposure when their
identity provider
collaborates with the NSA?
Say What Federation technologies
could they choose
that don't give their identity
provider access to web
browsing history?
So good news and bad news.
First of all, the IDP does not
get access to your web
browsing history.
It may get access to the events
when you actually
authenticated, but that's a
very small subset of your
interactions with any site.
But it's bad news.
I mean, if the NSA really wants
to know, they will send
a legal documents to your ISP,
not your search engine, not
your IDP, your ISP.
And your ISP will put a pipe
in the side of their router
and the NSA will know every
website you visit.
And given that this is known
to be happening, whether or
not they're incrementally
tracking where you happen to
get authenticated just hasn't
seemed like a big deal to me.
Now they are a variety of
techniques you can use to
increase your online privacy.
But as Ed Snowden said, whereas
the encryption flowing
across the wire is pretty good,
the endpoint encryption
is generally terrible
and weak.
And if you really want to be
secure, you have to look at
technologies like Tor, and
so on, which are kind of
inconvenient and icky to use.
And it's tough.
I mean, it is really,
really tough.
And I don't think this has
anything to do with
technology.
I think this is a policy
and legal problem.
ADAM DAWES: Agreed.
Well, we'll see where that one
works, how that one works
itself out.
SAML, OAuth, OpenID Connect,
Facebook Connect, IndieAuth,
Persona, sometimes it seems
like there are as many
Federation technologies
as identity providers.
Is there any indication that one
of these is going to win?
TIM BRAY: That's Bryant again.
Hey Bryant.
So, I think none of them are
going to win in the sense of
sweeping all the others away.
Inside the big company
Enterprise, SAML is pretty
dominant, pretty well
everybody uses that.
But I don't think SAML is going
to work with [INAUDIBLE]
on the broader internet.
It's just not designed
for that.
So I think OpenID Connect is
going to be widely deployed
out there because
it already is.
We're doing it.
Microsoft's working on it.
Lots of other people are.
OAuth in general, on which
OIDC is based, like for
example, the recently announced
Wordpress IPD is
based on OAuth 2.
Persona's got a chance.
We'll see.
By the way, I have my own little
individual identity
test bed with a little site
that you can log in to.
And I've wired it up to three
or four different flavors of
protocols, and I'm going to wire
it up to Persona in the
next few days.
And I think living in a
multi-identity protocol future
is actually not so terrible.
I think if we end up stuck
with a few, that's OK.
Nothing terribly wrong
with that.
ADAM DAWES: It does add a lot of
complexity for developers,
but hopefully there will be
tools that'll make it easier
for developers to manage.
Does the requirement to
pre-register my app's URL with
an OAuth IDP mean that I have
to let that IDP know about
secret pre-launch or
internal apps?
TIM BRAY: Well, yeah, but all
you really have to do is
register the URL, and name,
and optionally a graphic.
And I don't think we're actually
looking at those, to
tell you the truth.
ADAM DAWES: No, we're not
really looking at those.
And it doesn't give anybody any
ability to go beyond the
front door of what that
login page is.
So if you're in stealth
mode, just have a
stealthy front page.
And that should do it.
TIM BRAY: I think we're pretty
well out of time.
Thank you.
That was useful.
We're going to keep on working
through this on our blog, and
we'll probably do another one
of these ones on it, because
the questions keep flowing in.
ADAM DAWES: And please dial into
Tim's blog to continue
the conversation.
TIM BRAY: Ok.
Thank you for dropping by.